[Music]
welcome back to another exciting episode
Kos now I struggled long hard this week
I'm trying to figure out exactly what I
was gonna bring you guys because
remember we were going into my childhood
and we were going into cartoons and
stuff that I would watch but then there
was TV shows that I watched as well and
one TV show influenced me so much the
theme song stood in my head the action
the heroics was all that I ever wanted
to see I give a shout out to Adam West
rest in peace the original Batman he
formulated a large aspects of my life as
a youth I really would love to get that
statue from sideshow but today I bring
you sideshows Premium Format the Batman
and sideshows Premium Format the Joker
first we're gonna start with the
protagonist the Batman now this Batman
is made of mixed-media the cape on this
Batman this is the exclusive Batman as
well alright so it comes with to switch
out heads and to switch out arms one
switch out arm has Batarang and one head
has the long pointy ears the other one
has the short ears you can see a
distinctness and the faces if you look
at the pictures but each way that you
can display them is unique to these
statues of this high quality right so
this Batman I went with this Batman
the bat logo that's not encrusted in the
yellow shield because this reminds me of
the original first Batman's got soft
growing up not that on West Batman but
the Batman from the comic book DC when
you first came and he had the leather
gloves and it went from there so I went
with this premium format Batman The
Gargoyle is beautiful the detail on this
the statue is beautiful the Cape is
molded is not mixed-media mixed meet is
when it's made out of material but
there's mixed-media on the Statue with
the belt the costume is all mixed-media
the boots is made out of leather they
look really nice highly detailed so I
suggest you stick around to look at the
video right after this unboxing video so
you can see the pictures of them highly
detailed and up close and next we have
the Joker I can still hear that maniacal
laugh I always thought Heath Ledger did
a great job and his joke is portrayal
but I will have to go to the original
Joker and his portrayal of the Joker
which was beautiful the laugh resonates
to this day if any of y'all get a chance
to watch a DC Direct movie and it's
called
The Killing Joke this is what this
statue is from this Premium Format Joker
statue is from The Killing Joke if you
get a chance to look real closely the
highly detailed teeth this Joker came
with to switch out heads one with the
hat and one with the hat off with a more
maniacal face and the whole Joker is in
Premium Format mixed media the clothing
the stitching is beautiful so that's why
you got to house these things perfectly
they don't I'm going to do a couple of
videos in how to keep your statues clean
secure smoke free ultraviolet rays free
I give a lot of tips out if you have any
questions put it down in the comments
but trust me these statues are highly
detailed
well sought-after statues I needed these
to tell us statues the protagonists and
antagonists Joker being the antagonist I
needed these two statues together and to
display them both at the same time
because if you've noticed I've been
showing both in all series protagonists
and antagonists and I always feel that
you can have one side of the coin
without having the other and this llll
equates and accentuates both sides of
that but I always felt if you watch The
Killing Joke I always felt that the
Batman and the Joker were always the
same person mentally just one decision
differently that's separated to two so
when you watch the movie you can give me
some feedback on it what was your best
parts of the movie but it's a highly
sought after book I have the book I love
the movie adaption to it the joke is at
his finest in that book and in that
movie this statue is high quality it's
beautiful I love what sideshow has done
here and I'm glad that this is my first
DC line that I brought to you guys Kos
see you next week wanna bring you
another epic our statue I don't know
what it's gonna be
I have so many that I have to go through
but as you can see the background they
will get seen you will see them and
listen to the music while this guy goes
and gets ready for next week thank you
again like following subscribe iron
Lords podcast we do appreciate you guys
and oh go to go to law or Lords of
gaming dotnet where you can get
up-to-date information on the North's
trends and videogames and in our statue
and in our sports community also we're
having here you hear you sending out for
all writers and all
how can I say gossip columnist so put in
your application there come on join the
family at IOP
[Music]